what's a bridge in real life what's a
bridge it joins two distinct things I
think that normally would have been
connected otherwise okay so what a
bridge does is it joins two networks so
you know how we talk to that lands
before and we said you know a lamb is
all on one site or one building so our
school would be one lamb and say the
Cumberland High School and would be
totally separate right well if we could
build a bridge that would connect the
two they would still be two networks it
wouldn't just be one enormous network
because they still fundamentally
different there's different users on
each one there's different data and so
on
okay functionally they're quite
different but if you want to share
normally don't communicate you can build
a bridge between the two now the
important thing is that the two networks
have to have much the same protocol so
for instance we talked about protocols
like csma/cd
right so a bridge could join two
networks that both use this protocol
okay or you know in more simple terms a
network of Max versus a network of more
max okay same protocol same kinds of
communication going back and forth okay
so bridge just lets them talk to each
other but a gateway does a little more
you can probably anticipate how it's
doing to be different
a gamo will join two networks that has a
different protocol and you can see why
this requires more or different
technology because for instance if one
of them uses this protocol okay for
detecting collisions and dealing with
them and another network so your network
1 and networks do and they've got
different rules for what to do right for
instance these guys say after there's a
collision you wait a certain amount of
time and these guys say after there's a
collision just keep on sending data well
these guys are gonna have
with each other right they can't just
have a breeze that goes back and forth
so these guys would need a gateway that
stands between them if you like a
gateway kind of translates protocols
from one to another okay
lastly the whap and this is going to
feed into tomorrow morning's lesson okay
whap stands for we've actually got one
right here on the roof a wireless access
point
- Isis and what it refers to is you know
all these different kinds of
technologies were talking before these
are all in terms of physical actually
wired connections okay so maps are all
about all the different kinds of ways
you can connect without wires and as you
see tomorrow it's not just like Wi-Fi
there are so many different ways that
things can connect without wires and
we'll look at that tomorrow